الا جياني انفانتينو رئيس الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم ان منافسات كاس العالم قطر
2022 كانت مختلفه عن سابقتها وانها الافضل
في تاريخ المونديال على حد تعبير
الى الثناء الذي اعلنه مجلس الفيفا
بالاجماع على كاس العالم الفريده من نوعها
في قطر ونشكر كل من ساهم في نجاح كاس
العالم كل المتطوعين كل من شارك في جعل
هذه النسخه احسن كاس عالم على الاطلاق
واثنى انسان على خلود منافسات مونديال قطر
من اي مشكلات تذكر طوال المباريات الستين
الماضيه سواء داخل او خارج الملاعب
لعبنا اثنتين وستين مباراه حتى الان دون
اي حوادث في اجواء ممتعه وما زالت هناك
مبارتان وهذا امر يجب ان ناخذه بعين
الاعتبار
وكشف رئيس الفيفا عن الارقام التي ميزت
مونديال قطر مقارنه بالنسخه الماضيه في
روسيا
3.270,000 متفرج وكان العدد في روسيا عام
2018 يصل الى ثلاثه ملايين وثلاثه الاف
مشجع مع الاخذ بالاعتبار انه ما زالت
لدينا مبارتان معدل الحضور في المباريات
بلغها اثنين وخمسين الف وسبعه 260 متفرجه
وهو اعلى بواقع سبعه و اربعين الف عاما
كان عليه الحال في النسخه الماضيه اما
اعلى نسبه حضور فكانت في استدل بواقعه
ثمانيه 88,000
و960 متفرجه في مباراه الارجنتين والمكسيك